thomas pour la première fois donc depuis
la fin de l'évacuation à l'aéroport de
kaboul dans la nuit de lundi à mardi les
deux principaux responsables du
pentagone ont pris la parole une
conférence de presse attendu que vous
avez suivi thomas que peut-on retenir
des déclarations des autorités
militaires américaines
il ya une fois n'est pas coutume on est
sorti quelque peu des discours très
factuelle de la part de ses deux
représentants du pentagone qui ont
eux-mêmes combattu en afghanistan au
cours de leur carrière ils nous ont un
peu dé livrer leurs sentiments je sais
que ces derniers jours ont été
difficiles pour beaucoup d'entre nous a
par exemple déclaré lloyd austin le
secrétaire américain à la défense et
puis marc mulet le chef d'état-major à
lui parler de la douleur et de la colère
qu'il pouvait ressentir après avoir
constaté le résultat de ces 20 années de
guerre menée par les etats-unis en
afghanistan avec également une pensée
pour ces hommes qui sont tombés au
combat lors de cette guerre mais en tant
que soldat professionnel dit il il doit
contenir sa douleur et sa colère pour
exécuter sa mission jusqu'au bout il
s'agissait donc la première prise de
parole officielle des représentants du
pentagone depuis la fin de l'opération
d'évacuation quelque peu chaotique qui
s'est déroulé jusqu'à la nuit de lundi à
mardi dernier 124 mille civils ont été
évacuées une opération qui a donc été
saluée par lloyd austin vous propose de
l'écouter
nous venons de terminer la plus grande
opération d'évacuation aérienne de
civils de l'histoire américaine c'était
héroïque c'était historique
et j'espère que tous les américains
s'uniront pour remercier nos militaires
pour leur courage et leur compassion
on appelle à l'unité qui intervient
alors que les critiques pleuvent en
contre le pentagone et sa gestion
controversée de ce retrait d'afghanistan
oui le retrait très souvent présenté
comme un fiasco et les images de ces
dernières semaines ont beaucoup marqué
l'opinion alors derrière ce qui est
présenté comme un succès opérationnel et
logistique le pentagone aussi reconnaît
des erreurs aucune opération n'est
jamais parfaite a par exemple déclaré
lloyd austin qui a appelé à tirer toutes
les leçons possibles concernant ces
vingt années de guerre menée par les
etats-unis en afghanistan et puis ces
derniers jours des associations de
vétérans qui ont combattu en afghanistan
ont exprimé aussi de vives critiques à
l'encontre du secrétaire d'état
américain à la défense et du chef d'état
major qui auraient dû selon eux
dissuader joe biden de procéder à ce
retrait si soudain à des troupes
américaines en afghanistan certains ont
même appelé à la démission des deux
hommes écoutez la réponse de l'un des
intéressés lloyd austin en l'occurrence
mais nous ne devrions pas nous attendre
à ce que les anciens combattants
d'afghanistan soit plus indulgents que
tout autre groupe d'américains
j'ai entendu des opinions différentes de
chaque côté ces derniers jours et c'est
vital
c'est la démocratie
c'est l'amérique
et nul doute que les critiques vont se
poursuivre à mesure que la situation
continue d'évoluer en afghanistan suite
au retrait des troupes américaines
d'ailleurs le justin se rendra la
semaine prochaine dans le golfe pour
suivre les procédures d'évacuation
menées par les pays conjointement avec
les états unis dans la région merci
thomas bonnet en direct de washington